안녕하세요 시도입니다 여러분 혹시
지드레곤 님의 파워 뮤직 비디오
보셨나요 저는 꽤나 지드레곤 님의
진심이라 나오자마자 봤었습니다 몇 년
만에 움직이는 지옥 님을 본다는 것도
너무나 반가웠는데 저는 하나 더
반가운게 있었어요 바로 지드래곤 님이
뮤직 비디오에서 계속 신고 있던
신발입니다이 지옥 님이 신고 계셨던
신발은 오늘 소개할 내용의 주된
가락인 포라 슈메이습니다
포라인 슈메이커를 아는 분들도 분명히
있겠지만 모르는 분들이 훨씬 많을
것이라 생각해요 제가 다니는 패션
회사에서도 폴라에 대해 물어보면
모르는 분들이 대다 수더 포라는 많은
분들이 아시는 대규모 브랜드처럼
유명하진 않습니다 정확히 하자면
유명하지 않기를 선택했다고 말할 수도
있겠네요 폴라드는 온라인 마케팅과
판매를 일절 안 합니다 브랜드명을
온라인에 검색하면 일부 판매 사이트
가 뜨긴 합니다 그런데 보시면
인스토어 올리라고 적혀 있거나 아예
볼 수 없게 되어 있어요 또한 촬영
협찬도 거부하고 할인도 하지
않습니다이 포라의 공식 홈페이지를
들어가면 브랜드명과 함께 키보드를
아무렇게 친듯한 요상한 글씨만 적여
있어요 그외에 아무것도 없습니다
브랜드나 제품에 대한 정보도 이메일을
보내 주소도 기본적인게 하나도
없어요이 요상한 글씨를 긁어서 검색해
보니까 기사가 하나 뜨더라고요 라든
대해 다룬 해외 기자인데 보니까 그
기자도 아무리 찾아도 뭔 뜻인지를
모르겠다는 내용을 적었습니다 포든의
공식 인스타그램에 들어가도 올라온게
많이 없습니다 며칠 전에 인스타그램에
게시물이 한 번에 몇 개 올라왔는데
이건 2024년 8월 이후 반년 만에
올라온 것이었어요 올라온 내용은
포든이 참여해 만든 짧은 영화 몇
편입니다 물론 포라의 복식과 문화를
낄 수 있는 옛날 느낌 지극한
영상들이 하지만 지금 포라의 2025
SS 제품들이 점차 판매되고 있는데도
이에 대해 직접적으로 다른 게시물이
단 한 개도 없습니다 그러니까
사람들이 모를 수밖에 없어요 정보
자체가 거의 없으니까요 폴라드는
판매처도 적습니다 우리나라에서
유일하게 폴라드는 판매하는 매장은
탱고로 속 꼬모 하나예요 일본에는
그래도 몇 군데 있는데 도버스트릿
마켓이 대표적이고 제가 지난 영상에서
소개한 교토의 바드도 그중 하나입니다
포라의 주무대인 영국과 인근 나라에도
주요 도시별로 바잉하는 곳이 한두
군대뿐입니다 그런데이 바잉을 할 때도
제약이 있다고 합니다 2000년대
초반 디자이너 송명희 님이 비엔나에
있는 본인의 송 부티크에 포라의
바잉하여 했을 때 일하는데요 송명희
님이 어렵게 포라게 컨택해서 옷을
바잉하고 싶다고 했습니다 이웃 저
고른이 포라
님에게 너무 옷을 많이 구매하는 것
아니냐며 좀 적게 구매하도록
설득했다고 합니다 명일 님은 끝까지
여성복과 더불어서 남성복을 구매하고
싶다고 의사를 전달했으나 입구가
시작되기 전에 남성복의 바잉을
취소시켰다 합니다 아니 다른
브랜드들은 매장에서 이전 시즌 구매한
공급을 기준으로 더 구매하기를
요청하는 면에 라드는 하지 않 본인의
철을 지킨
거죠 면 라드니 도대체 누군지 그가
만드는 옷들이 어떤지 궁금하실 텐데요
먼저 포라는 캐나다 인으로 런던의
로얄 아카데미 오브 파인 아츠에서
공부한 뒤 그의 이름에 딴 브랜드를
1987년에 런칭했습니다 현재는
브라이튼에 있는 100년이 넘은
오래된 기계가 있는 본인의 작업실에서
홀로 일하고 있고요 그는 패션계에서도
비밀에 숨겨진 지극히 보수적인 인물로
유명합니다 제가 열심히 찾아본 바로는
지금까지 인터뷰도 공식적으로 딱 한
번밖에 안 했더라고요 근데 그
인터뷰도 전문이 500짜리 책에서만
볼 수가 있습니다 그림에 떡
이더라고요 라든 슈메이커는 대표적인
아티잔 브랜드 중 하나입니다 아티잔
브랜드라 하면 핸드메이드로 소량의
제품들을 만들고 전통적인 방식을
사용해 지속 가능한 패션을 추구하는
브랜드를 의미합니다 라드는 슈메이커는
이름답게 신발로 시작해서 년대부터
자켓과 셔츠 등의 레디투웨어 그리고
가방 조명 갓까지 다양한 것을 만들고
있습니다 포라의 작품들은 영국
시골부지 그리고 미국 남북 전쟁과
산업 혁명시대에 이르기까지 다양한
시대상에 걸쳐 있습니다 공통점이라면
전부 굉장히 과거의 것들인데요 그의
작품은 무려
1779년 아카이브에서 영감을 받아
제작한다고 합니다 그 우리가 흔히하는
빈티지 복각과 시대상이 좀 많이
다르죠 그가 만든 것들을 보면
공통적으로 새상품 같지가 않습니다
어떤 건 정말 그 시대에 만들어진
것이 아닌가 하는 생각이 들
정도고요이는 그가 만드는 모든
작품들에서 고수하고자 하는 철학입니다
어쩔 때는 이런 빈티지 효과를 내기
위해서 그가 만든 것들을 몇 주 동안
땅속에 묻어 두기도 한다고 합니다
라에서 유명한 들이라면 여러 가지가
있는데 일단 자켓이 유명합니다
아티저널 한 디자인이 특징으로 오래전
복식인 섹 자켓의 특징을 따르는데요
브이존이 일반적인 자켓에 비해서 좀
높습니다 그리고 목까지 채울 수 있는
단추가 있고요 그리고 당연하게도
이름답게 신발이 유명한데요 라스트가
과장되게 올라온 디테일이 특징인데이
자칫 보면 좀 요정구두 같기도 합니다
라드의 제품들의 단점이 있다면 가격이
정말정말 폭력적입니다
자켓은 국내 가격 기준으로 600만
원
정도해요 라드는 여러 셀럽들과 패션계
인물들의 독보적인 사랑을 받고
있습니다 마르젤라였던 종 갈리아노는
그의 작품들을 사랑한다고 공개적으로
말한 적이 있고 도스 마켓의 CE이자
레이 가와쿠보의 남편인 아드리안 조
또한 라드의 작품에 대해서 패션을
넘어선 것들이라고 평가한
있습니다 리티 중에 포라를 좋아하는
것으로 가장 유명한 사람은 제가 아는
바로는 브레드 피트입니다 포라를
좋아하는만큼 브래드피트는 공개
석상에서도 여러 번 포라의 제품을
입고 나왔어요 그리고 서두에서
말씀드렸던 지드래곤 씨도 포라의
제품을 즐겨 입습니다 본인의
인스타그램이나 공식 석상에 직접적으로
여러 번 포라의 옷을 입고 나온 적이
있지만이 옷에 대한 정보 자체가
애초에 적으니까 사람들이 많이 알지를
못하더라고요
저는 포라는 슈 메이커스의 제품을 딱
두 개 갖고 있습니다 먼저 소개해
드릴 건 포라의 가방인데요 이름은 빅
청키 백입니다이 가방은 작년 4월
도쿄에 있는 도버스트릿 마켓에 갔다가
구매하게 됐어요이 제품은 제가 아는
선에선 몇 시즌 폴라드 나오는
캐리오버 상품입니다 색상도 초록 핑크
등 다양하게 나오고 사이즈도 세 가지
종류로 나옵니다 제가 구매한 건 그중
중간 사이즈인데 작은 건 여성분들이
되기 좋은 사이즈고 큰 사이즈는 흔히
말하는 보스턴백 정도의 크기입니다이
제품을 구매한 이유는 일단 라든 제품
중 가격이 그나마 괜찮았습니다 그리고
포라의 레디트 웨어도 매력적이지만 좀
매니악한 성격이 강한 제품들이라 오래
사용할 수 있는 가방이 좋겠다고
생각했어요 가방은 앞에 지퍼로 된
주머니가 하나 있고 메인은 통입니다
어 13인 노트북이 꽉차게 들 도의
사이즈입니다 구획되어 있지 않아서이를
안 좋아할 분들도 분명히 있겠지만
저는이 투박한 맛이
좋더라고요 그리고 가방의 가족도
구매할 때부터 이곳저곳에 크랙이 잔뜩
있었습니다 이게 개체마다 조금씩
달라서 제가 도버스트릿 마켓에서
구매할 때도 동의 제품에 전부
꺼내어서 보여주셨어요 조금씩 개체
차이가 있으니까 이중에 마음에 드는
걸 고르라고
프라만 청난 건 아니지만이 가방을
만약에 구매하실 분들이 있다면 꼭
있는 재고를 다 보여 달라고 하시는
걸
추천드립니다 크로스 형태로 매 수는
없고 탑 팬들이 그래도 적당히 길이가
되어서 저는 어깨에 껴서 들고
다니기도 하고요 그냥 손으로 들고
다닙니다 잘 로고 하나도 안 보이는
제품이지만 빈티지한 가죽의 질감이
매력적이고 또 들고 다닐수록 그
빈티지함을 제 생활로 더할 수 있어서
제일 자주 들고 다니는 가방입니다
두 번째 제품은 얼마 전 교토 바드에
방문했을 때 구매한 프라드 a
옥스포드 슈즈입니다 제가 구매한 건
브라운 컬러인데이 제품은 텐꼬르소
꼬모에 최근에 들어오지 않은 색상이라
고민하다가 구매했어요 폴라드는
검색하면 가장 많이 나오는 이미지 중
하나가이 옥스포드 슈즈인만큼 브랜드의
대표격인 제품이라 할 수 있겠습니다이
옥스포드 슈즈를 검색해 보시면 다양한
색상이 나오는데 비단 색깔만 다양한게
아니라 어 신문 을 넣은 디테일도
있고요 어 뭐 다양한 스타일로
나옵니다 처음 바드 매장에서이 신발을
신고 하루를 꼬박 고민했어요 내가
정말 잘 신을 수 있을 것인가 라든
보여주는 크롭한 기장의 바지의
스타일링은 좀 자신은 없지만 제가
자주 입는 넉넉한 바지에 입어주면
고자에 신을 것 같더라고요 좀 통
있는 바지에 신으면이 한껏 위로
치솟은 구드의 라스트가 삐져
나옵니다이 신발은 발볼은 좁고 길이는
길게 나와서 발볼에 맞춰서 신어야
하는데이 바지밑단 아래로 앞코가
나오는게 매력적이더라고요
어이 포라는 슈메이커의 신발에 대해서
참고로 말씀드리면 일단 박스가
없습니다 그리고 저는이 더스트 백만
받았는데 더스트백 안에 있는 신발을
열어보면 신발이 무슨이 신문들이 같이
있어요이 신문들이 뭐 특별한 건
아니고 우리나라로 따지면 뭐 조중동
정도 되는 그냥 되게 평범한 신문이
고 아무튼이 매니아들 중에서는이
꾸깃꾸깃한이 신문들을 모으는 분들도
있다고
합니다음이 신발의 착화감에 대해서
설명을 드리면 좀 생각보다
편하더라고요 저는 엄청 딱딱할 줄
알았는데 하루를 꼬박 신어봐도 발이
아프진 않더라고요 그리고 호불호가
갈릴 수는 있지만 바드 매장에서
구매할 때부터이 신발은 비한 보강이
되어 있었습니다 가격이 있는
제품이라서 이게 개인적으로는 차라리
마 편하더라고요 라든 메이커스와
유사한 아티잔 브랜드로 존 알렉산더
스켈레톤 앤드류 드리프트우드 등이
있지만 가장 근접한 브랜드는 바로
엘레나 도슨 있니다이 본인의 이름을
딴 브랜드를 만든 엘레나 도슨은
2000년도에 라든 슈메이커의 의류를
함께 출시한 장본인으로 라든 함께
일하다가 2006년에 본인의 브랜드를
직접 만들었습니다 엘레나 도슨의 의복
또한 19세기 빅토리아 시대를
따르는데요 작은 팀 만 움직이면서
자연적인 소재만을 사용한다고 합니다
다만 조금의 차이가 있다면 엘레나
도슨의 옷들은 조금 더 해체주의적이고
로맨틱한 분위기를 자아내는 디테일들이
있습니다 엘레나 도슨의 대표적인
제품으로는 해킹 자켓과 코트가
있는데요이 제품들의 이름 앞에는 4x
12x 등 숫자가 들어가는데 이건 압
단추의 숫자입니다 이것도 자켓의
디테일을 따른 것으로 보이는데
개인적으로는이 4x 자켓은 좀
탐나더라고요
국내에서는 한남 꿈대 가르송 매장에서
찾아보실 수 있습니다 이런 아티잔
스타일을 국내 브랜드 중에도 취급하는
곳이 몇 군데 있습니다 하나만 오늘
소개하자면 가장 꾸준한 모습을
보여주고 있는
LBX LBX 2017년부터 조금씩
몸집을 키워나간 브랜드인데요 처음에는
테일러링 위주의 의복을 다루다가
2021년 정도부터 아티잔 스타일의
브랜드로 거듭났습니다
저는 개인적으로에 대해서 굉장히
존경스러운게 꾸준히 작업일지를 매
제품마다 블로그에 작성해서
올려주십니다 저는 꽤 초창기부터이
브랜드에 블로그를 봤는데 제품을
만드는 과정부터 참고자료와 브랜드
등에 대한 내용을 늘 자세히
적어줍니다이 작업 일지를 보나 직접
입어보나 착용감과고 모드를 굉장히
신경 썼다는게 느껴집니다 저는 지난
시즌 나온 피셔맨 스터만 있는데 아
다음에는 꼭 자켓이나 코트를 사고
싶습니다 인기가 요즘 많아져 가지고
조금 고민한 사이에 바로 품절
되더라고요 가격도 위에 소개한
브랜드들에 비해서 훨씬 합리적이고이
맥클레즈 편집샵 등에서도 찾아보실 수
있으니까 방문해서 입어 보시는 걸
추천드립니다 폴라드는 처음 보면이
비싸고 낡아 보이는 걸 도대체 왜
좋아하는가 하는 의문이 당연하게 될
것입니다 물론 저도 그 의문이
아직까지 지워지진 고요 개인적으로
생각해 봤을 땐 라드의 굽히지 않는
제조와이 브랜드를 운영하는 방식에
대한 철학이 목하는 것 같습니다 그는
마케팅이나 촬영 등을 거부하면서
본인의 작품들이이 상업적으로 소비되는
것을 거부한다는 점에서 아르데 포베라
면모도 지니고 있고요 포라는
쇼메이커스 터 시작해서
lcbx지 아티잔 브랜드는 아직
주류에 속하는 스타일은 아니라고
생각합니다 하지만 제가 봐온 바로는
유행까지 아니더라도 사람들이 관심을
더 갖고 있고 어느 정도 앞으로
몸집이 더 커질 만한 스타일이라고
봅니다 제가 소개하지 못한 국내외
아티잔 브랜드도 많으니까요 본인의
스타일과 관심도에 맞춰서 찾아보시는
걸 추천드립니다 오늘 제 이야기는
여기까지입니다
[음악]
감사합니다 고양이들에 새끼
m